welcome to this video playing white
against a GF Aki F okay let's see
Queen's Gambit around the triangle I'm
eating a couple of peanuts I hope it's
not too distracting yeah we got a stone
ball and this is actually a version of
the stone wall which is almost
unplayable I am I'm talking from
experience I played this is black
against a very strong Grandmaster in the
tournament many years ago and he told me
how you know kind of this every Russian
screw by nose kind of tone you know the
stone wall you cannot play this against
this Queen c2 Bishop f4 and in fact I
really lost lost badly now but this guy
went into the same line that that I went
into okay it's not it's not like why
this um has just fled out winning or
anything but it's a very very nice
position with the rook here on the G
Hall and some play
not coming to f4
should I play Knight f4 now yeah I could
play that I could for steak oh maybe
just take first easier easier to play
well on f3 is still had this check now
I'm threatening f3 I think it looks like
rather annoying move to face okay if I
take f5 now and the age of 17 yeah well
f3 is hanging unfortunately
yeah what's the best yet it really looks
like there should be some almost
decisive firm decisive idea I cannot
believe see something entirely
convincing mm the g4 it said it's good
it's still a good position but it
doesn't look like winning
hmm
I don't really understand what's going
on why can I not take now yeah and you
played this instantly of course like
it's the most normal move in the world
yeah before saying I seem but still
hmm really have a hard time to believe
this night through what is playing queen
d3m if I go rook air-five face
Haruka d3 okay
Quincy three orders of Quincy three I'm
just yeah let's do this cool
it's probably just exchange Queens queen
African g7 made
J
I need to get rid of this this book if
possible it's really annoying this look
yeah but this looks hmm quite quite
bleak from like 96 check
my g6 is quite annoying 96 King g7 mm-hm
okay let's just take it
check
I can also just win this point I think
yeah okay look look aged four I can can
do that well that's not really helping
much
mmm how do I get okay this is easy jack
yeah it's not not that simple actually
yeah it's not that simple to win at
least for 30 seconds on the clock
who
c7 c8 hopefully with a check this is
very important
time warning I can't believe this crap
check
they cannot even move this it's not it's
it's unbelievable
painful what the crap game by me how can
you not win this really I've got to one
minute on the clock
caring maybe this wasn't wasn't too
great yeah you know this was already
tricky but I think I was completely
winning again
Luke f8 would win Lukey a twins how did
I not win here it's not so easy actually
I'm now taking on d5 okay
then this is a check on e6 this is why I
cannot end it with King t3 he went out
of this check with the temple really
amazing dad you can just take it would
be a tent curtains no idea anymore yeah
but I was just spending far too much
time in this complications earlier okay
thanks for watching